that was the the super yellow guys for
everyone watching
they had a big chess theme and i was
wondering if
well no you guys done because you didn't
see it but if people at home wow we've
seen a huge blunder
happening by the pontiac uh napoli
actually trying to trade the queens
trying to head to an end game but he's
just missed this last move white jumping
in with his knight giving check
and if that knight is taken then there
are consequences white's queen will jump
into the position
actually black's about to lose either a
rook or a queen
uh napoli actually we see it on his face
he did not
even consider that move that's why we
always say look for checks first
in every position because if they work
they're extremely strong they're
extremely powerful and the pony actually
just a one-move blunder in a solid
position he should have slow played it
he rushed maybe feeding the tension
feeling the pressure and the
momentous occasion um he wanted to
eliminate that by trading queens and now
he's dead lost and the mistake was
bringing his queen into the middle of
the board and
magnus immediately punishing it knight
jumping into the position attacking the
king
and attacking the rook if this knight
gets captured i mean if it doesn't you
can just take the rook
if it gets captured though then suddenly
white's queen would jump into the
position giving check
and when the king moves no matter where
it goes there's an attack opened up
against the black queen
so yeah nothing to do now